Breaking Bad is arguably one of the best and
most talked about shows ever. But while the
principal cast have mostly all gone on to
high visibility projects, some of the actors
who played minor roles have had trouble finding
their way out of the ABQ.
Julia Minesci
Julia Minesci landed the role of Wendy, Jesse's
customer and occasional paramour-for-hire,
only as a result of a "midlife crisis, turning
fifty" thing, according to an interview she
did with AMC. She was so convincing as a prostitute
that a guy supposedly drove up and tried to
proposition her while they were shooting a
scene for the show. Unfortunately, Breaking
Bad wasn't the career catapult she thought
it might be. With only one other short film
credit to her name in the six years since
she started the show, her turn as the root
beer and meth-loving hooker of The Crosswinds
Motel may have turned out to be just a flash
in the pan.
Marius Stan
After playing Walter White's mean boss Bogdan
at the A1A Car Wash, Marius Stan hasn't had
any acting work since Breaking Bad. But that's
okay—he's actually a real-life scientist
with a PhD in Chemistry who works as a Senior
Computational Energy Scientist at Argonne
National Laboratory outside of Chicago. Probably
beats running a carwash.
Lavell Crawford
Comedian Lavell Crawford played Huell, who
was basically a one-joke character. As the
enforcer for crooked lawyer Saul Goodman,
he barely spoke a word on the show—but still
managed to be hilarious in every scene. His
post-Breaking Bad credits don't boast much,
but they do include roles in American Ultra
and the Adam Sandler movie The Ridiculous
Six.
RJ Mitte
Before becoming the breakfast-loving son of
Walter White, RJ Mitte had a kind of sporadic
acting career, like a few background roles
in Hannah Montanna. He's since moved on to
Switched at Birth, a series on ABC Family,
and landed a few movie roles. But we're still
holding out for Mitte to land a cooking show
where he just makes breakfast every episode.
Seriously, we'd binge-watch this guy eating
pancakes and eggs for hours.
Matt Jones
Landing a string of roles on network TV shows
like NCIS and Mom after Breaking Bad ended,
Matt Jones first won our hearts as Badger,
Jesse's scratchy-voiced underling.
"I wanna be a knight."
These days, he's got the role of Pig on the
Nickelodeon show Pig Goat Banana Cricket.
Man, first Badger, now Pig. Dude's like a
one-man zoo.
Charles Baker
Skinny Pete was half of the comic relief duo
who sporadically showed up in various henchman
roles for both Jesse and Walter. Although
he played a spaced-out meth addict, Charles
Baker is actually a classically trained stage
performer and an accomplished pianist in real
life, as demonstrated by his beautiful playing
in the episode "Hazard Pay."
(piano playing)
"You sound great!"
After Breaking Bad, he did some work on mainstream
shows like NBC's The Blacklist, but he's since
turned his attention to independent film work
like the sci-fi thriller Approaching the Unknown
and Nicolas Winding Refn's 2016 film The Neon
Demon. Those are probably creatively fulfilling
projects for sure. But toss some of those
names out to a general audience and they're
going to look back at you like you just recited
Badger and Skinny Pete's Star Trek pitch:
"I'm on the Starship Enterprise mackin' on
Yeoman Rand while the Andorian with the disruptor
is back on Talos IV or whatever."
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which Breaking Bad character you like
the most...